hey guys what's up it's such and such
from somewhere california
i have a king here for you today it's uh
using psychedelic mushrooms
for anxiety depression uh
there's a lot of benefits it could be
used for if you micro dose it
just started growing it we got our grain
spawn right here
and then we have our agar plates full of
mycelium
um basically my wife has really really
bad anxiety
so she just doses on these mushrooms and
gets real trippy it makes her feel
better no more anxiety
less stress just easier for her and
better for her to live her life
uh let me know what you guys think i
love the show
thank you for having me yeah yeah but we
take a bunch of mushrooms
maybe the anxiety's gone she's seeing
like gargoyles in the corner and [ __ ]
like is that her day no no burning you
have to you don't know about mushrooms i
don't
have gunshrooms huh have you done drugs
no have you done them
hmm he's talking about micro dosing you
take like a small amount i've heard
micro dose in like if you do like
adderall
christian they say uh micro dosings
similar but without all the symptoms of
vateral yeah how do you mic
how would you micro how did you do that
i don't know dude
yeah dude don't ask questions first of
all don't ask me questions those are his
arch nemesis okay
drugs are my arch nemesis ask the
attic over here about the drums yeah
keloid have you done them before with
your
christian sorry have you done them
shrooms yeah uh yeah once
okay it didn't really have any effect on
me really like it didn't
take enough no i took a lot i thought
like i was gonna see
like i thought a couch would be talking
to me or something everything just
seemed uh
slow brighter and i just felt like a
little happier
yeah you get the yawns a little bit with
shrooms you get those shroomy yawns
i'll say this i did them one time with
my buddy growing up and he turned into
the only chinese kid that ever lived in
our town
we had some stout batches dude we used
to get them fresh
off of the field oh hot off the manure
is that where they get them from
underneath manure
yeah some of them right yeah like some
of the spores i think that there's like
a fertilization process that happens
with like between manure and
um i think something that's already in
the garden i know for a lot of like
military guys and
ufc guys when they do show signs of ct
they're recommending micro dosing
oh it's huge now supposed to help with
your brain i see more people that are
you'll see people out at night that are
on mushrooms and not on anything else
they're normal yeah and there's no and
is there there's no side effects next
morning i went the other night with my
friend and he was on him and
i didn't know what was going on and then
suddenly i was
like the faces he was making weren't
didn't fit with whatever was going on
like we were actually at spades comedy
show and he's like this
and i'm like dude what why don't your
face match with what we're looking at
yeah and then
and he's like i'm having a great time
yeah and he said that he said he was on
mushrooms
somebody also had a baby seat at david
spade show the other night so that was a
little bit weird
but um i feel like you've done mushrooms
nick i really like mushrooms i've only
probably done it
10 to 15 times
for over 15 years but uh
recent here is p.o laughing as he said
that about
recently i i ate some and
my girlfriend's friend's fiance he he
makes chocolates of him he sells them in
bars but i ate some when i was watching
ufc
fight and jewels came in the room and i
was just like washing the fight with my
hand on my knees like
you're really into it you're sweating
you're sweating yeah and she said i look
like this lady giving corner
she's a me is that nelly yeah but did
you look like you had anxiety as a
question
you're giving corner advice
[Laughter]
but uh yeah they're fun look man i'm all
for it i think there's definitely some
some great pathways to good things going
on out there there's a company now
called compass that's the first
um i think they are like a
like a it's almost like a marijuana like
distillery but for mushrooms
that's on the new york stock exchange
now so like they're definitely gaining
uh
traction amongst like regular just if it
can help it's a natural product who
gives a [ __ ]
totally dude especially when you have
people on all this other [ __ ] people
getting
people popping opioids somebody's cat
ate an opioid the other day and they
caught it [ __ ] it jumped in front of
a
the l train or something in new york all
the [ __ ] that's going on like
it's good to see like some natural stuff
getting uh getting out there
i'm all for it man i'll be down for that
micro dosing yeah
i um if it's legit i don't get it from
my [ __ ]
kyle over there you know i need some
legit [ __ ] yeah i think there's ways
like yeah and i think it's definitely
there's ways to use stuff where it's
like
you're just trying to party and then
there's ways to use stuff where it's
like you're trying to figure out things
that could help you
you know i used to think mike rowdosing
was tripping with the guy from dirty
jobs
i could see that dude i tweeted that
once
[Laughter]
and how did it go uh no not a lot of
trouble
come for the gang buzz stay for the
second hand jokes
is